the happiest place on earth has been
closed for about 10 months
and it probably won't be reopening
anytime soon california isn't allowing
theme parks to reopen until the counties
they're located in have fewer than one
covid infection
per 100 000 residents for seven
consecutive days
the rate here in orange county currently
exceeds that by about 90 fold we're
gonna be stubborn about it
california governor gavin newsom said in
october new some stubbornness
is one of a kind every other disney
property in the world has reopened
in california some of disney's retail
and dining is allowed to open but the
rides and attractions remain closed
the city of anaheim meanwhile looks like
a ghost town
the mouse provides 78 000 jobs and is
the center of the local economy
[Music]
disney world in orlando opened in july
as florida's case rates were climbing
the reopening amounts to a breathtaking
effort by a corporation
to prove that it can safely operate at a
highly dangerous time the new york times
observed
youtubers created dark parodies of the
reopening don't belong here
but the search never came this is the
tale of two disney's
and two radically different approaches
to managing the kovid 19 pandemic
you got a lot of people in your
profession who waxed poetically for
weeks and weeks about how florida was
going to be just like new york
wait two weeks florida's going to be
next just like italy wait two weeks
well hell we're eight weeks away from
that and it hasn't happened
the media savaged florida governor ron
desantis when he
and a handful of southern gop governors
pushed to reopen most
businesses in early summer of 2020.
desantis's strategy from the get-go had
been to shield florida's seniors
by issuing executive orders to
temporarily ban nursing home visitations
and prohibit readmission of coveted
positive patients
in contrast to new york governor andrew
cuomo's order
forcing nursing homes to accept covid
patients a couple months later with case
rates falling national review editor
rich lowry asked where does ron desantis
go to get his apology
then when cases surged over the summer
los angeles times columnist michael
hilsick delivered on the requested
apology
sorry you're even worse than i imagined
he wrote
but by the end of the summer cases were
falling in florida
and rising in areas of the country that
were in full
or partial lockdown california which had
the nation's most stringent policies
related to covid19 began to
experience a massive second wave in
november
florida was also seeing a spike in cases
and deaths though it was less severe
while the california and florida
approaches to covid19 were vastly
different
their outcomes began to look remarkably
similar
if some in the media had been too quick
to condemn desantis
others had also been too quick to
declare victory for newsome in april the
atlantic had extolled california's
dramatic success
in containing the coronavirus pandemic
what's clear about the impact of
newsome's policies
is that they've taken a devastating toll
on working class california residents
the golden state shed eight percent of
its jobs compared to five percent in
florida
it experienced the fifth highest drop in
gdp among u.s states
and a much higher drop in tax revenue
california now has
more total cases per capita and is
approaching florida's total deaths per
capita
despite having a younger population
california residents have been flouting
the lockdowns and challenging them in
court
a recall petition for governor newsom
has gathered more than three-quarters of
the required 1.5 million
signatures to make the ballot
there are probably 50 000 people
in a three square mile that are out of
work right now
due to the restrictions placed by
california's governor
here in anaheim fred brown has been the
general manager of desert palms hotel
in the literal shadow of disneyland for
24 years
so far he's had to lay off 80 employees
including his own daughter
if we don't have guests i don't know how
long
some of these hotel owners are going to
be able to last without
throwing in the towel and going into
bankruptcy i don't think the state of
california has done the best job keeping
businesses afloat
mike aphram shut down his shuttle
company in march laid off a hundred
employees and has been unable to reopen
since well unfortunately i think a lot
of small businesses
related to the resort or even unrelated
to the resort
are not going to survive they won't come
back this is a death knell
for tens of thousands of jobs these are
working class jobs
and hundreds of small businesses in and
around the resort he's
surfing precious freedoms away from the
private sector and increasing our
residence and our workers reliance on
government just to get by
trevor o'neill is an anaheim city
council member he says tourism accounts
for almost 100 million dollars of
annual tax revenue for anaheim that goes
a long way to be able to fund
our vital city services our public
safety our police and our fire our
road repair everything that a city has
to do and
allows us to be able to keep our taxes
on our residents low
disneyland as a corporation has been
very successful in opening its parks
around the world
and including the one in florida and
they have proven to
know what they're doing and know how to
do it safely and securely
so i don't see why it would be any
different for us here in california or
in anaheim
disney is known for its expert handling
of logistics and the company drew
widespread praise when it brought back
the nba playoffs here in florida by
creating a so-called
nba bubble that successfully prevented
any players or staff from covet
infection over a two-month span
california is also home to universal
studios and
six flags in addition to smaller
amusement parks with no giant corporate
backer to float them through a 10-month
shutdown
the contrast between california and
florida reflects
growing evidence that lockdowns are not
an effective strategy for managing a
viral respiratory epidemic
our estimates show that lockdown had a
really dramatic effect on reducing
transmission
a june 2020 paper in nature claimed that
lockdowns would save
three to four million lives worldwide
but it assumed without evidence that
slowing the spread was due to lockdowns
rather than voluntary behavior
and that as lockdowns stretched on they
would remain just as effective as in the
early days of the pandemic
after it was published places with
stringent lockdowns including california
the united kingdom and italy experienced
second waves
a possible theory is that lockdowns
become less effective over time
because the public grows weary of the
social isolation
and starts gathering in private
households on a more frequent basis
according to contact tracing data in new
york 74 percent of cases were contracted
inside people's homes you close bars you
close restaurants you close theaters you
close stadiums you close
mass gatherings where do people go
they go home come to my house big city
mayors who promoted aggressive lockdowns
are beginning to change tack
even amidst large case loads chicago's
lori lightfoot and washington dc's
muriel bowser have pushed for reopening
restaurants for indoor dining and san
francisco nla's mayors have allowed
outdoor dining to resume
a january 5th study by a research team
at stanford compared countries that shut
down
non-essential businesses with ones that
took less restrictive public health
measures
like only banning large events and
discouraging international travel
it found no evidence that the more
stringent lockdowns contributed
substantially to bringing down the case
rate economist lyman stone told reason
in may of 2020 that his study of the
lockdowns revealed no correlation
between the timing of a state or
nationwide stay-at-home order
and the spread of the virus so we have a
couple different data sources that
basically
track your cell phone which is a little
bit creepy and what we can see
is that policy choices like shelter and
place orders had almost no impact
on when people began to socially
distance people were already socially
distancing before the lockdown
social distancing works stone's early
findings are consistent with the
stanford study which found that exposure
to
information about the virus and its
risks was a stronger driver of
anti-contagion behaviors
than the specific nature of the
government restrictions
neither california's statewide
restrictions nor florida's more
laissez-faire approach
have proven effective at suppressing the
virus
but various asian governments and
australia have
for now mostly accomplished that feat
and not
primarily through lockdowns for instance
the densely populated city of hong kong
has experienced
fewer than 200 kova deaths out of a
population that exceeds 7 million
but authorities there imposed only one
short-lived lockdown
in a single neighborhood experiencing an
outbreak in mid-january
stone attributes the overall low case
rate to the city state's aggressive
travel restrictions
and targeted public health measures
which were enacted early in the pandemic
we should not hesitate to pull the
trigger on closing borders
second mask early mask often everyone
should wear a mask
and they should do so as soon as you
know that you have a threat of a
pandemic
information is the most powerful tool
getting people to understand the risk
and protect themselves but after that
centralized quarantine anyone who is a
positive test in any close contact of a
positive test
we need to isolate california governor
gavin newsom
lifted his stay-at-home order on january
25th
on the grounds icus will have the
required capacity in several weeks
but the state has withheld some of the
data they used to make that projection
theme parks will remain closed in the
meantime disneyland has opened one of
its parking lots
as orange county's largest vaccination
site so far
california has had one of the slowest
vaccine rollouts in the nation
with the rollout of the vaccine which
has not been proven to be the best roll
out compared to other states
maybe there is a way we can responsibly
sooner open up so that we can get back
to business and get
back to surviving